[Air horn sounds]
[Jennifer gasps, screams]
JENNIFER WALTERS
Whoa, Jesus! What the hell, man?
BRUCE BANNER
Still in control, no overwhelming
feelings of rage?
JENNIFER WALTERS
No! A normal amount of rage!
BRUCE BANNER
You do revert back to Jen-form
when you sleep.
JENNIFER WALTERS
Was the air horn really necessary?
BRUCE BANNER
For comedy, absolutely.
♪♪
BRUCE BANNER
This is a multi-year journey
you're about to embark on.
JENNIFER WALTERS
Yes! Woo!
BRUCE BANNER
Who's your best friend?
JENNIFER WALTERS
Nikki.
BRUCE BANNER
[Buzzer sound] Spandex.
Spandex is your best friend.
Being a Hulk asks for balance.
You have so much more to learn.
Yes!
JENNIFER WALTERS
I'm clearly nailing it at
all of these things.
BRUCE BANNER
If you want to go back to your
life as a lawyer,
I respect that.
JENNIFER WALTERS
He doesn't mean that.
♪♪
HOLDEN HOLLOWAY
More and more eccentric super humans
are coming out of the woodwork.
[Laughing]
HOLDEN HOLLOWAY
We are going to launch a division for them,
and I want the She-Hulk
to be the face of it.
EMIL BLONSKY
Jennifer Walters...
...namaste?
JENNIFER WALTERS
I have a serious conflict of interest.
This man tried to kill my cousin Bruce.
HOLDEN HOLLOWAY
Yeah, that's quite alright.
JENNIFER WALTERS
Oh.
People only care because
I'm representing Emil Blonsky.
NIKKI RAMOS
I think they care because they're like,
"Hey, that girl's green!"
[Crowd screaming]
NIKKI RAMOS
Jen, do your thing.
JENNIFER WALTERS
God, I really like this outfit.
I'm not proud of this.
♪♪
WONG
Ms. Walters, we answer to a higher power.
Our universe is on
the edge of a precipice.
JENNIFER WALTERS
I am a lawyer. We do things by the book.
WONG
Mhm... The Book of Vishanti?
JENNIFER WALTERS
No, the book of American, uh, laws.
[Groan]
BRUCE BANNER
Whether you like it or not,
you're now a Super Hero.
JENNIFER WALTERS
Let's do this.
You know that friend you had in
high school?
Who was way cooler than you were,
attractive, got all the attention
from everyone?
Hello!
BRUCE BANNER
I think I'm jealous.
Is that what I'm feeling?
♪♪